IKAI LAN: Oh, hey, we're live.
[LAUGHTER]
We have these new lights in the
studio, so I can't see the
[? signalist. ?]
And again, we're live.
So I probably shouldn't
be saying all this.
Hi, everybody.
Welcome to another addition of
Google Developers Live, an
Apps Script.
My name's Ikai Lan.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Arun
Nagarajan here.
And we're here to hold
office hours.
So Arun and [? Killian, ?]
who you can't see, is off
screen right now.
They've been working on
some cool stuff that
they want to demo.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: We're not going
to show it right away,
but we'll pre-announce
it, I guess.
IKAI LAN: Not show It.
[LAUGHTER]
Oh.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: We're going to
put it in an official blog
post and launch it in that way,
that we can actually get
our official stance out there.
But we'll pre-announce it for
the folks that tune in--
the loyal guys and girls
that listen in.
So we're going to actually
working on a simple app that
we're going to put
out very soon.
It's around the election, so
obviously we have a week and a
half to go to the election,
so a timely interesting
application.
And the idea is that we're going
to be using the Google
Civic API, which lists your
polling place, based on where
you're registered to vote, and
it'll show it in a map and
allow you to create a calendar
event and other things that
we'll walk through.
But the basic idea is to build
a full-featured sample web
application built on top
of Google Apps Script.
And developer relations--
we're developers ourselves--
and the point is for us to go
through the exercise that you
go through.
It's got a lot of good value,
and then ultimately, we'll
release the source code, as
well, for you guys to take and
really tweak it and add
more features and
capabilities to it.
IKAI LAN: And I know that you
guys are working on a series
of blog posts describing how it
was done, but what are some
of the different services?
I've seen some stuff
that's pretty good.
It's a web UI, and there's some
cool stuff going on--
integrates such Google
accounts.
What are some different
services you're
using to build this?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah, so first
and foremost, it's an HTML
Service application that uses
jQuery pretty extensively to
do both Ajax calls to the
adjacent service, and also to
build a fairly decent looking
UI, I would say, clean and
concise but crisp, as well.
And so that's the interface
aspect of it.
HTML Service serving up a
jQuery, which does a bunch of
stuff for the client
side, as well.
But behind the scenes, we're
using the Map service to get a
static map of where the
polling location is.
We're using UserProperties to
store things about the user
and their secure location, so
when they come back the next
time, we remember the address.
We're using the Document app
to create a document with
driving direction to where
the polling place is.
We're using the Calendar app
to create an event with a
reminder and the location in
there, so you can get a
reminder the day before the
election to go vote, and where
you go vote.
And we also give you the ability
to send yourself an
email with the details on
where you got to go.
So those are some of services
we're using.
Let me see if I'm forgetting
anything.
IKAI LAN: It's like you guys
are using every single API.
[LAUGHTER]
You just have to figure
out how to cram in
URL Shortner, [LAUGHTER]
Google Tasks and BigQuery.
Oh my goodness, BigQuery.
So if you haven't seen our
office hours, we did a
BigQuery office hour live
session on Tuesday, and
there's a video.
So BigQuery is a tool that
allows you to do a daily
analysis on very large
data sets.
So I get an email sometimes
where people say hey, got a
spreadsheet.
It's got 50,000 rows.
It's very large.
Now, that is very
large by a lot.
I certainly couldn't
do that by hand.
But we're talking about
BigQuery, we're talking
about-- let's say you've got a
data set that's terabytes of
data, or even a couple hundred
of gigabytes of data.
It's pretty large.
You could put that in
the spreadsheet--
I actually don't know
if you could.
I think the answer's no.
You can't put a couple
hundred terabytes.
Your copy/paste buffer's
not that big.
But if you wanted to write
scripts and build a UI for
your big data, that's certainly
something worth
looking into.
So check us out at
developers.google.com/live,
and go to our YouTube channel.
Because we've recorded it at
youtube.com/googledevelopers,
And just scroll down
a little bit.
Unfortunately, YouTube always
picks the worst preview image.
So they've got a picture
of me going [LAUGHTER]
like this, and it's
like a DMV photo.
So definitely check that out.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: There's going
to be a way change that, no?
IKAI LAN: There is, but
I'm in a bad mood--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
I never have been accessed
to anything.
People just keep taking away
my privileges around here.
For good reason.
Very good reason.
So I want to talk about this
currently unnamed app, Because
you guys should all keep a look
out for it on the blog.
We have a blog post going
up very soon.
That said, I think it's
googleappsdevelo
per.blogspot.com.
And if you're ever not sure how
to get to our blog, just
go to your favorite search
engine and type in Google Apps
Developer Blog.
I don't know that that's
actually easier to remember.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Google Apps,
which is what we represent.
IKAI LAN: Which is what we do.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Developers,
which is what you guys are,
and blog, which is what
we're talking about.
IKAI LAN: Which is what
the stuff is going on.
So that's an announcement,
too.
A third announcement is that we
still have spots in our Los
Angeles Hackathon.
I know that a lot of people
don't like to sign up for
things way in advance.
I know I have a friend that
goes hey, are you free in
February for lunch.
And I'm like what are you--
what is this?
I don't even--
no, he's visiting from
some city or other.
So I would that's coming
up on November 13.
So we still have spots.
I know it's still kind
of early, so we'll be
periodically reminding you.
I'll be there.
Arun's going to be there.
[? Killian's ?] going
to be there.
And when you guys see this
Election app they're working
on, you're going to want to be
there, because you want to bug
them about it.
I'm sure you guys love
hearing about it.
No, you guys haven't even
started talking about it yet.
You're not sick of it.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: It's
a pre-announcement.
Yeah, so check it out.
And we're going to actually
release it to the Chrome Web
Store, so we'll talk through the
process for releasing your
web apps through the Chrome
Web Store, as well.
So this blog post will cover
a lot of the mechanics.
Obviously, we ran into some
interesting problems
ourselves, which we'll bug our
engineers about, and hopefully
it'll improve the whole product
and affect whole
community in a positive way.
So there's a lot of good
reasons why we do it.
And if you have ideas for
other sample apps--
this extensive sample app that
you want us to work on.
Shoot us an idea, and maybe
we'll talk about it during
office hours and see what
the interest level is.
And we'd love to do one a
quarter, a few a year to keep
the product moving forward, and
also to give you guys more
sample code to work with.
IKAI LAN: Right.
And I think you guys are
planning on doing a special
live show about this
application, how it's moved.
It's going to be a very
technical deep dive.
It's not scheduled, yet.
And I'm sorry we're still
looking for a slot.
But if you just keep looking at
developers.google.com/live,
we will post when
that's going on.
And don't worry if you miss it,
because we do record every
single one of our shows.
So that'll be up.
These next few months, you're
going to be seeing a lot of
these, what call
special shows.
We're going to be one of these,
and we're going to have
a few more interesting shows.
But if you guys have any ideas
for shows you want
to see, let us know.
I had one idea, and I don't
know how it's going to go.
It's the Reading Rainbow idea.
I think the only one that's on
board, where we talk about
some of the books we like.
I don't know.
[LAUGHTER]
Let's just try it.
I mean, what's the harm?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah Well, in
all seriousness, we're going
to show the code.
We're going to walk down the
structure of the code.
Obviously, it's a sample app,
and it's not going to do
everything the API can do.
But take a look through, submit
your questions, and
we'll actually maybe even do
some live coding of new
capabilities, depending
on how things go.
So I know we have a lot coming
up on that, what we're calling
topical of GDLs
IKAI LAN: Topical--
I don't think we should
use that.
Topical sounds like something
you put on your skin.
[LAUGHTER]
So we'll come up with
a better name.
I call them special editions.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Special
editions, where we actually
show code and walk through
layout and what process we
went through, and workarounds,
though sometimes you have to
end up using--
all sorts of details about the
code itself, so that it's not
just a Q&A, but you can actually
watch and learn and
replay it and use it
as a resource.
IKAI LAN: So I'm looking at
the Q&A, and I realized I
didn't post a link to the Q&A
this time, so we're going to
have to remedy that for
the next office hours.
But in the meantime, let's go
ahead and skip to the live
Hangout and see if there's
anyone on.
IKAI LAN: Can you see that?
All right, I'm just making sure
you have a line of sight.
It looks like you're
obstructed here.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: I'm sorry.
I have to look away for a
second for the video.
Is that Bill?
Is that right?
IKAI LAN: I see Bill.
BILL: Yeah, that's me.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Hey,
Bill, how are you?
Good morning.
BILL: Good.
How are you guys doing?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Good.
IKAI LAN: Good.
BILL: I was waiting for today,
because we've got a pretty
long string without
release notes.
So I'm expecting something
really big coming
at it any day now.
IKAI LAN: Oh, they're
on to us.
No, nothing super big.
But you're right.
We haven't done any releases
in the last few weeks.
I'm not sure when the
next release is.
It's either--
BILL: It's eminent.
IKAI LAN: Is it tonight,
next Thursday?
I don't know if there's anything
that's what we call
user-facing, and then we do a
lot of stuff behind the scenes
to make sure stuff's always
working better.
But no, release notes
today, not yet.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: But do stay
tuned for next week.
BILL: OK, because I will look
back, and it's been a long
time since we've gone this
long without some release
notes of some sort.
[LAUGHTER]
ARUN NAGARAJAN: No, it's
something just to give you a
sense for, as Ikai said
for the release notes.
So there are features and fixes
and improvements that
are going through,
weekly probably.
But we call through the list of
things that are changing,
ensure that they're working the
way we wanted to, ensure
that they'd make sense for
us to document and
highlight to our users.
And those are the ones
that make the actual
release notes webpage.
It's not a one-to-one
correspondence to the actual
improvements and fixes
that you may see.
There's certain things that are
internal upkeep that we
keep doing and ensure
that systems
running smoothly, obviously.
And hopefully the next one will
be a bit longer than the
ones before.
IKAI LAN: I hope so.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, I know when we're going
through release notes
sometimes we're like,
what is this?
[LAUGHTER]
I don't even know what
this, really.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah, so if we
don't know what some fix is,
we probably won't
write about it.
[LAUGHTER]
So that's one of the reasons,
as well, as you can imagine
there was backlog of
housekeeping and things that
we go through.
BILL: Cool.
Well, I do have one question
today, and it's about ScriptDb
Ikai, I mentioned last time
that I have a little
experiment running to see--
IKAI LAN: Yeah, I was waiting
for your email,
and I never got it.
Sad.
BILL: I'm not done yet.
IKAI LAN: OK.
Like the release notes you've
got to wait for the--
[LAUGHTER]
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yes.
Yes.
It goes both ways.
BILL: Well, good.
My impression was that the COUNT
method should return
more, the number of objects that
are in there, but it's
been a little erratic.
And most frequently, it returns
a number somewhere
around 50,000, not necessarily
right on.
So I was wondering, does the
number of objects return?
Because I know there's a hard
limit of 50,000 objects for
other queries.
But my assumption was the COUNT
method would return the
number of objects independent.
It would stop and see the
1,000 [INAUDIBLE]
2,000 objects.
Can you comment on that?
Do you know anything specific
about the COUNT method?
IKAI LAN: Well, I know a few
things about the COUNT method,
so to describe a little
about how ScriptDb
works under the hood.
I'm fascinated by data stores
for some reason.
What happens is I've been
tracking and monitoring these
ScriptDb issues that people
have been reporting, and
there's some pretty interesting
ones out there.
That the [? nSTREAMS ?] has been
trying to get to [BURP]
the bottom of n.
So if you think of a data store
like this, you've got
the objects stored somewhere,
and this would be like a
storage unit, or like
a library shelf.
Right, you have a library shelf,
and we've also got an
index, and in the index would
be something like a catalog
inside a library.
We would say where
is this book?
When you do a query you're
hitting the index, and you're
going through these things, and
then you're going to the
library to actually fetch the
book and fetch the data.
So that's what's happening when
you do a ScriptDb query
is, you're going through this
index first-- you're going to
this catalog.
I don't even know if
they still have
these anymore at libraries.
[LAUGHTER]
I know that when I was a kid--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: The Dewey
Decimal System.
IKAI LAN: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They still have the Dewey
Decimal System.
I don't know if they have the
little cards that you have to
flip through.
So what's happening when you
do a query is you're going
through these cards, you're
flipping through them, you're
finding all the things you want,
you're pulling out these
cards, and then you're going
and you're individually
fetching these items back.
So there are a lot of COUNT
Query My understanding of how
COUNT Query works is that it's
going through this index, and
you're just counting
a number of cards.
Now, one of the issues
with that is that
there's no way to--
in a distributed system, it's
very difficult to do it
cheaply, where you have indexing
synced up with
something perfectly.
I mean, we do our best, and in
most cases, we've got our
bases covered.
But what does happen from
time to time, and
I've seen this reported--
the symptoms as reported on
the issue tracker is that
you'll do a query on something,
you'll say hey,
I've got five results, and
you'll go to the data store
you try to pull back those
five, but you won't
go pull them back.
Because they've been deleted or
updated, or the index is no
longer valid.
Now this is a problem, and
we're working hard
to try to fix this.
And it's my understanding
that COUNT first off,
works on the index.
If we're having inconsistency
bugs with the index and the
actual Datastore, COUNT is not
going to be exactly accurate.
And we're working on resolving
these when we can.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And it's also,
I think, the larger the
database, the more likelihood
that COUNT is slightly off,
because the data is
[? sharded, ?] right.
IKAI LAN: It's likely from
a probability standpoint.
In that, let's say there's 1%
chance-- it's not a 1% chance!
[LAUGHTER]
It's much smaller than that.
But just because it's so
large the chances that
you're going to be off.
But it should be very,
very small in the
order of single digits.
I'm not saying that--
for the most part, if you're
doing stuff on the order of
single digits, and you're
doing these large COUNT
operations, it's fine, right,
for all impractical purposes.
Now I understand why
you want an exact
count on a lot of cases.
So the issue with the index is
that there are two things--
I'm not really answering
your questions.
This is a really roundabout
way of doing this.
One is that first we need to
figure out how COUNT works, if
COUNT does return the number
of objects in the query.
Because we don't keep a running
count, especially of a
query, because we can know
ahead of time all the
different queries you're
going to do.
You might say give me everyone
whose first name is Arun, and
I might say give me all the
people that have a favorite
color of red.
And I can't know ahead of
time to index these.
If I index them ahead of time,
quote unquote, "to keep a
running count," I knew
you were always
going to execute this.
Every time someone adds a new
ScriptDb item, where there's a
person's name Arun, I increment,
and whatever
someone deletes an item, I
decrement that number.
And that way I can return that
count to you, and what we call
a constant time operation,
in that it just happens
immediately, right.
There's only one thing
that happens.
Now when you have to go through
indexes to do counts,
we have to traverse through each
one of the index times is
one by one, so you go one, two,
three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine, ten.
Now it's very, very fast,
because it's an index, but
there's still a traversal
happening.
And there are ways to get this
down, but not as fast as what
we call this Constant COUNT.
So what I suspect might be
happening is, I wonder if the
count, when it goes through
these 50,000 things, it's
hitting some kind of time
limit or limit.
There are two things are
possibly happening.
One is that we're doing a full
query, or at least we're doing
the index query.
The index knows to stop at
50,000 or whatever the number
is, and we're returning
that number to you.
Or the second is that we're
hitting some time limit, and
we're turning that to you.
And I don't know what the
behavior is off the top of my
head, but hopefully there's a
little bit of insight there as
to how COUNT works.
Now, the flip-side of this
is that if you were doing
optimization--
if you know that Arun constantly
queries for his
name, it is a good practice
to keep a running count.
And some people, they call this
a counter cache, right.
Now again when you do something
like a counter
cache, you have this problem
where it might get out sync,
and you might be off
by one, again.
It's like we're just solving
the same problems over and
over and over again.
So I know that you're not using
this for this purpose.
I know you using it to
do some benchmarking.
So this may or may not
be a helpful answer.
I mean, hopefully it may explain
some of the issues
you'll see at a larger scale
when you do notice that one or
two items go missing because
it's fairly unlikely that when
you're working with ScriptDb of
a couple hundred objects,
anything will go missing.
But when you're at 50,000, if
you're keeping track of them,
and you notice an
inconsistency--
now again, when I say go
missing, I'm not saying the
data is deleted.
It's there.
I'm saying that it's not
updating the index.
You might see issues
like that.
BILL: Well, to give you an idea,
right now I just I just
ran my counter and the
COUNT returns 56,691.
I did exactly what you said was
I track the number that I
was stuffing into it.
According to my script, I've
stuffed 157,000 into it.
So I haven't verified it.
Because I know the script
stopped a couple of times, due
to a time-out.
So maybe it recorded some that
didn't actually go in.
So I haven't actually verified
that there's in fact, 56,691
objects in there or the 157,900
objects, but what I do
know is it there's probably
more than 56,000 in there.
And the last time I ran this
since it's been sitting there,
it was a different number, and
returned me on the account, I
think 100,000 one time.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And how
many did you say
you think you inserted?
BILL: Up to 57,000.
I wouldn't actually ask--
I would have put it on
tracker or something.
I was looking for some insight
which Ikai, you just gave me.
So I think I need to
build a script to
actually count them--
pull them out in small batches
and actually count them, so I
know how many that are actually
in there and compare
that to what COUNT's returning
And the fact that you've told
me the count, isn't
really a count.
It's a go and look and see what
the index is telling me.
That's useful to me.
So I can--
IKAI LAN: Don't get me wrong,
the index should be completely
synced up with the data.
BILL: And it may be, but my
first gut tells me that it's
not giving me-- well, it it's
giving me different numbers.
So let me go look at
a little bit more.
I'm learning some stuff from
this, so I'll report back on
what I find.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And Bill, the
end goal of this is for you
understand what the limits are,
and also from a record
COUNT a size standpoint,
correct-- for a byte size
standpoint.
BILL: Yeah, my goal of the
experiment was to know when
I'm building an application for
a customer that they tell
me their data set is x number
of records, I can say then,
well, we can use Spreadsheet,
or we can use ScriptDb, or
we're going to have to put it in
some other database outside
of Apps Script.
So it's just an idea so I have
a sense of right now 200
megabytes or 100 megabytes
doesn't really tell me
anything about how much data
I can really stuff into it.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right now we
talk about in terms of bytes,
and you want to know in
terms of records.
BILL: Yeah.
I don't know those bytes are
those bytes of information.
I assume there's
some metadata.
IKAI LAN: Yeah, there's
probably some kind of
[INAUDIBLE]
BILL: So that's what I'm just
trying to get a sense of, and
it's fun playing
ScriptDb, too.
IKAI LAN: There's a
serialization method we use
here at Google called
protocol buffers.
And you think of something like
JSON except make them
type safe, and you need
to have a definition--
sort of type safe.
That' what a protocol
buffer is.
So sometimes it's not always
obvious how much
space your taking up.
So what you're doing is
very good experiment.
For instance, someone might
say a size limit on--
we don't publicize size limits,
because we to figure
out what it means.
For instance, if we have an
RPC limit that's, say, 10
megabytes for a given a given
RPC, the right way for us to
implement something is to
batch a really big RPC--
a 50 megabyte thing, we'd break
them into five chunks.
But what we need to do is,
there is that overhead of
taking whatever data you are
wrapping inside this protocol
buffer and sending
it over the wire.
And I have to figure
out what the
actual persistence mechanism.
But you're right, it's not
an absolute one-to-one
correspondence as in
my JSON object is
this long as a string.
It's like with someone's
protocol buffer, and protocol
buffers can also be compressed,
which makes it
even more confusing.
But on the note that you're
bringing up something that's
very, very important, which
is how do we do counting?
And this is something that has
been brought up over and over.
So in a SQL database,
people tend to be--
I don't call them spoiled,
but SQL is powerful.
[BEEP]
I mean, SQL you can say select
COUNT (*), and [BEEP]
you'll get back [BEEP]
[BEEP]
to COUNT, [BEEP]
and that's because [BEEP]
it's effectively scanning
indexes as it's
going row by row.
And it's single-homed, so you
don't tend to have these
problems of going out to
multiple systems and trying to
get back a count.
So with SQL you--
no, I don't want to go too
much into SQL internals.
That's not fun.
But I was going to say,
basically the same thing.
We have to go by row by row by
row, especially if you've got
a complicated query that you
want to do a count on.
So something that people often
ask me is what's a good, fast
way do counts.
And one way to do counts is,
what we talked about, where
you keep a running count.
But this tends to only be useful
if you know ahead of
time a priori, what you're going
to be counting total
items or items that have a
certain very popular criteria.
Now, one thing that's really
interesting is a pattern is if
you have tons of data, and you
don't know how to do what we
call approximate counts.
So a good example of this
in action is say Gmail.
In Gmail, let's say you do a
search on my name in your
Gmail, and you'll see something
like 1 to 25 out of
thousands, you notice that
there's not an exact number
and for good reason, right.
Because the chance that you'll
go all the way back is low, so
why should we spend the
computational effort to
actually count everything.
So one technique that's commonly
used-- and I don't
know if this is what they use in
Gmail-- but I've seen uses
what's called sampling.
So you have something like
Gmail, a good example is you
say, how many emails do
I have from each Ikai?
Well, we'll take the first 2,000
emails, and you'll see
that per 2,000 emails,
I have maybe 50
emails from Ikai, right.
And therefore, if I can assume
an even distribution all the
way back till the end of time,
I know that I keep a running
count of how many email messages
I have, which is
100,000 via 50.
Well, I'll take 2,000--
100,000 divided by 2,000,
and now my mask is
going to break down.
But that number--
it's a sampling, so
it's kind of like
election polling, right.
And that's one way of assuming,
but we don't give
you the exact number.
And that's one strategy when
it comes to counting.
Because ultimately, the question
you have to ask
yourself is why am
I counting this?
Do you care if it's 640?
Is you care if it's 740?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Especially in
the ScriptDb, where the data's
not necessarily homogeneous,
right.
So you may have five
chairs and three
emails and five books.
So the count of objects
sometimes takes a lot longer
to sync up, because it's not
as valuable like you said.
IKAI LAN: And again,
approximation tends to be more
important to people
than the actual.
But that's why it's also
horrible and wrong.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: But in case of
this experiment, the count is
very interesting.
IKAI LAN: Yeah, we need to
figure out why it's stopping.
I mean, just out of curiosity,
Bill, how are you recording
the kind of objects
that you insert?
BILL: Well, so I
just open here.
So I create batches, and then
stuff those batches.
And then after those batches are
stuffed and I get an all
OK back, I record that in
a script property--
just increment the
script property.
IKAI LAN: OK.
OK, I see.
So one thing I want to look
out for-- and this isn't
something that would
inflate the number.
This is something that would
deflate the number.
There's some window and window
stuff going on here.
Defining the number is if you
write the ScriptDb twice in a
quick succession, because
you can use lock
service to lock it.
I suppose that work, especially
since you're not
doing very, very fast writes.
But what that would do is that
you would end up what I call
losing rights.
If you say that you've recorded
150,000 items, your
numbers probably 155,000 or
something higher 150,000,
which still doesn't really
explain the discrepancy
between what you're seeing of
150,000 and say 50,000.
BILL: OK.
Well then, I will play with this
a little bit more, and
then when I get a better idea,
let you know what I find.
IKAI LAN: Yeah, I'm going to
make Arun my secretary and
make him remind me when we've
got a backdoor task.
To figure out how this COUNT
stuff works, because I think
it's important that we create
abstractions that make it so
you don't have to understand
how this works.
I mean, it should just
work for you.
But sometimes when you get to
be an advanced user, it is
important to understand
how things work.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah,
absolutely.
And especially when you're in
this decision making process.
BILL: Yeah, and it really
just goes back to your
approximation versus exact.
The reason I'm doing exact is
just to find where the limits
are, but really what I'm
looking for is an
approximation.
If someone gives me an idea
of what the data set is.
I approximately know that that's
not going to fit, or
it's going to fit.
It only needs to be,
in order magnitude.
IKAI LAN: Right, not knowing
your magnitude.
You're relatively close.
BILL: No, not at all.
That's a little off.
But I mean, if I determine I can
hold a million objects of
this size, and they tell me they
have 200,000 of really
big objects, I know I
might be in trouble.
So that's all I'm looking for is
to get a sense of what does
the size quotas mean?
Because I'd hate to get to
the point where I got an
application, and I roll it out
and on the first week, we had
the cap and have to rethink
everything.
So--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Are
the ScriptDb--
BILL: It's just to
get a sense.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: --quotas per
user or per script author or
per script?
IKAI LAN: This is a question
that we have to answer,
because some things are for
the script author and some
things are per user.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: But they're
never per script.
IKAI LAN: Wait, let me think
about this for a second.
I believe ScriptDb
is per script.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Per script.
So you could theoretically
create multiple libraries.
IKAI LAN: I need to draw the
diagram of this, because
there's some holes in my
own knowledge, right.
And this will force me to really
understand this thing.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And then
force us to fix it.
IKAI LAN: Yeah.
And I'm surprised Arun hasn't
taken a shot at me yet about
putting together
that ScriptDb.
It was waiting for--
It's coming.
Anyway, I'm really sorry
to cut you off, Bill.
We're running out of time.
BILL: You're not.
We're done.
Good.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: No, this was
a great, great question and
great reminder for us to really
investigate this, and
it's not going to be
an immediate thing.
But hopefully, we'll get the
information that we need to at
least sanity check
documentation, improve it were
necessary and then hopefully
also, generally,
clean up the quarter.
BILL: It's all good.
[INAUDIBLE]
Thanks.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Thank you.
IKAI LAN: Thank you, Bill.
All right, and thank you
everyone for watching.
This video will be
posted again on
youtube.com/googledevelopers.
And we had talked about
some cool stuff today.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
Yeah.
And then stay tuned for
the Election app.
IKAI LAN: Stay tuned.
Watch out for our blog
post, all right.
Thank you all very much this
is Ikai Lan signing off.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Arun
Nagarajan here.
[TECHNO MUSIC]